le canada a déjà été un des pionniers
dans la vaccination est maderna le
saumon fillon en a vu la capacité de
produire rapidement des vaccins
efficaces
on aurait pu les avoir un peu plus tôt
ici les premières doses du vaccin contre
la coved 19 qui seront administrées aux
canadiens proviendront d'entreprises
étrangères father bio ntech et moderna
ont misé sur une nouvelle technologie
pour remporter cette course mondiale aux
allures de sprint moderne au big one
tech avant même la pandémie qu'avec 19
essayer de développer des vaccins à base
d'arn contre les cancers contre d'autres
types de maladies infectieuses
donc il y avait deux jeunes l'expérience
il y avait déjà la technologie les
vaccins à arn messagers consiste à
injecter la séquence génétique d'une
protéine du virus dans le corps humain
ont provoqué une réponse immunitaire au
canada un seul groupe temps de
développer un vaccin avec cette
technologie mais n'a toujours pas
commencé ses essais cliniques
ce pour jour ce seuil est de le produire
il faut aussi le produire vite comme
certains pays ont fait l'entreprise
canadienne la plus avancée et medicago
17 sociétés qui ont obtenu un contrat du
gouvernement fédéral pour fournir des
doses
c'est la seule qui étaient établis au
pays la pharmaceutique de québec
développe un vaccin qui utilisent des
particules pseudo virales fabriqués par
des plantes
elle vient de lancer ses essais
cliniques de phase 2 et commencera la
phase 3 en janvier
technologie de production de vaccins de
pfizer sont très différentes et nos
talents nous ont produit un vaccin qu'on
appelle recombinants donc on a besoin le
système vivant qui produisent le vaccin
et on doit le purifier tout ça prend un
peu plus de temps que les vaccins à
hélène qui sont des vaccins qui sont
chimie au siècle dernier
le canada était une figure de proue dans
le domaine dans les laboratoires dirigés
par armand frappier au québec on met au
point et au produit des vaccins contre
la tuberculose la poliomyélite et la
grippe mais à la fin des années 80 le
gouvernement provincial met en vente les
activités commerciales de l'institut je
pense pas que c'est une erreur parce que
modèle d'affaires était pas et est pas
fait pour le développement commercial
est un modèle plus académique donc
production à plus petite échelle par des
laboratoires qui n'ont pas les mêmes
préoccupations ne paient que les
industries privées les laboratoires
connaught de toronto vont subir le même
sort
si on avait pu développer d'autres
capacités canadiennes à développer et à
fabriquer des vaccins alors là on aurait
été en meilleur état
le canada a donc perdu son emprise sur
la production de vaccins si le pays fait
bonne figure en recherche
aucune grande entreprise privée capable
de concurrencer les géants étrangers
n'ont émergé pour pouvoir répondre à une
pandémie sa production de masse et ça il
y en a pas au canada medicago a reçu 173
des 214 millions investis par ottawa
pour développer un vaccin canadien alors
que le gouvernement américain a injecté
18 milliards
selon andré veillette le gouvernement
fédéral doit corriger le tir pour
l'avenir à la prochaine pandémie
ça serait beau qu'on ait déjà cette
infrastructure leur ce personnel formé
chez ces gens professionnels qui sont
experts dans la découverte de vaccins
dans la fabrication de vaccins au canada
se sont servis en premier c'est ceux qui
ont investi massivement en recherche et
développement et qui ont des premiers
capacités de production en général qui
sont locales medicago a l'ambition de
devenir une pharmaceutique
incontournable son vaccin ce qu'a prouvé
cet été si tout va bien
l'entreprise compte produire 80 millions
de doses au cours de l'année prochaine
[Musique]